he's Michael Irvin Pro Football Hall of
Fame how are you originally I'm doing
well Richmond both roles of good choice
Giants are great choice because of you
know that defense ran and and of course
that marked it if you win in New York if
you win in New York you can write your
check to anywhere in the rest of the
whole wide world you ever want to do
whatever you ever want to go but I'm
with you I'm going Oakland man I'm going
Oakland are if I have cause just because
because of the quarterback situation
rich are going to have a Bugaboo of a
deal dealing with the Eli Manning cuz
remember now that we talked about this
I've been through this before when I
first got the Dallas and we didn't do
well I remember reading the paper after
every Sunday's loss and they were time
to get rid of coach Landry time you know
hi Colin what are you talking about it's
time to get rid of coach Landry are you
guys crazy I had just got in here and I
thought no way you get rid of coach
Landry you know let him play it out and
then Jerry Jones cam comes in and he did
what everybody has been saying he got
rid of coach Landry and they turned on
him like were you doing your thermos
dude in the war you don't get rid of
legend and I think a lot of that's going
to happen with Eli one day pretty soon
pretty soon but they they were asking
for it here this year and then when
people when they sat apparently what are
you doing that's going to be a tough
deal to deal with in New York well I
mean yes that's true but if you have
somebody that you draft second overall
and you've got your quarterback of the
future and you're part of that and then
you you have him sit there for a year or
two like Aaron Rodgers did behind Favre
and we also all that worked out and you
have a situation in with the Giants
where I think we all believe you you you
tinker with the offensive line a little
bit and everybody stays healthy you've
got yourself a ready-made situation
don't you yes yes you do you turn it's
the easy turn what happened with the
Giants this year I think happened more
off the field than happen on the field
you know and I think it was a residual
or what you saw now you got the guys
coming out saying yeah of course
La Coruna issue and those locker-room
issues are then showed up on the
football field because the talent is
there you're absolutely right about that
but now can you fix those locker room
issues can you fix that Eli Manning
situation because that could be a fix
and one year the right coach comes in
and brings those guys together you know
arm and get in a good situation with the
line you're right got the second pick
you can find they're so good
quarterbacks coming out you got to find
the right guy even though they're
transitioning it's never going to be
easy
go on Eli is never going to be one for
Brendan Rodgers people forget that
wasn't an easy transition no it was a
I'm done I'm back I'm done no I'm back
I'll tell you what we need you to be
done for it no I'll tell you we're not
done you know remember that Mike Michael
Irvin here on the Rich Eisen show okay
Irv let's role play here let's role play
you are Michael Irvin I'm Jerry Jones I
call you into my office and I say well
come on in Michael here take a seat
there's some papa john's over there if
you're hungry okay what should i do what
should we do here in the next few months
to make sure we're on the right
Superbowl track what should I do and you
say what what a couple things that I
want to do this you know I'm sure with
you you know what I said last year I
wanted to go get another receiver in
juju you know and I still think that a
place that the Cowboys have to go you
know and finding another oh and let me
tell you why I wanted you as I talked to
him about a lot I like jelly and now
just starting to see it rich and I think
I told you guys about this after I had
them on game change once I got the guy
when I get those kids on game changes to
show we do an idea to work out with kids
and I'm up close with them I can tell
you which guys coming out of that right
then I could tell you it's you I'm
measuring his physical ability and
there's and his mental capability is
mine how he sees the game and I'm
measuring the intangibles of how much he
loves playing this game I saw it it's
honest man did you see any guys like
Fred I think that guy got down
need a guy like that deck you play as in
number two but will one day merged until
the number one you know and that's what
the context kind of receiver that'll
really help them right now and and I
would look at that
I like the advances my defense are made
I'm gonna find the Dallas Cowboys right
now you know and I'm gonna tell you this
rich I'm stayin attack I'm standing
right where I am
with the coaching staff and and I'm
writing off this year not as a monster
but as a Jew that I can use next year
saying we have overcome adversity before
because it's a lot of adversity the team
went through without having on well with
all the all the GLA your stuff hanging
over there here to bring the injuries
and everything so so I'm going to stay
tight but there are certain things that
I'm going out in this draft and then
there's all season to pick up for this
football teams well I mean now you
mentioned you wanna number two to grow
into a number one so I'm assuming you
still believe the guy you refer to as
your son in Dez Bryant is still a number
one receiver and I say that lightly
telling you that last year week number
nine was the last time that he had a
hundred yards receiving in a football
game is he's still a number one receiver
in this league earth oh yeah you see
when he gets certain opportunities it
shows up better than other opportunities
you know and I said you know there's a
difference when he came in and me and
Tony showing him the ropes
that's one thing you know it's a whole
nother thing when you're the receiver
and now the quarterback is the guys you
have to show the ropes in this
quarterback getting a deck that that
stepped out of his Lane this year and
trying to get that relationship with DES
and and throwing pass doing things
attention says that he would normally
take he would normally take but but that
doesn't mean to me that there's is not a
number one receiver it just means that
they have to grow together and as we
remember that back is just a second-year
player and it's unit but for what he's
done and it
two years it's nothing short of
incredible and the growth he did and the
play the way he has played so he still
learned his a lot to learn so yes
absolutely did
still no more repeat Pro Football Hall
of Famer Michael Irvin my compadre from
NFL gameday morning we're on the air for
two shows this coming week with wildcard
weekend all right let's get into the
teams that are still playing right now
which do you think has the best
opportunity for an upset this weekend
Titans winning in Kansas City or do you
like Tam in st. in in New Orleans you've
got the Rams in Atlanta and then
obviously you've got yourself Jaguars
and Bill's what do you think Michael
Carolina Carolina in the state people
call it an upset you know what I mean
we're talking about the visiting team
the visiting team winning all right so
then let's remove cam from the equation
since obviously he's an MVP player from
and and he's taking his team to a Super
Man you go there limb and I don't know I
think the Rams are the Falcons have been
too offensively inefficient for Gurley
and golf and Cup and Watkins and I think
they I think the Rams win this thing and
I think they beat them up first I know
they have been off but I just watched it
Wisconsin beat Miami that couldn't throw
or three yards out to the game they
could complete a three yard out
something like that with Atlanta has all
the physical gifts there to be explosive
and explosive and they were last year as
explosive as the Rams you just don't
know if they click this week because
there's something missing there
something missing we've been trying to
put our hands on it touch it as a soccer
that this who do what what's going on
what's going on but at any moment they
could have that day where Matt Ryan
looks like the Oh MVP and everything
because they have all the tools in the
toolbox
if the tools just if they use the right
tools at the right times they click then
they think it'd be dangerous now it's up
to it's up to the Rams to make sure that
that doesn't happen that they don't
click and they don't be dangerous but
what it they can be a headline brought a
Brockman send out that video with Irvin
headline like Michael Irvin calls Alex
Hornibrook the Matt Ryan of college
football but I think he just gotta do to
that is that that proper headline from
that from that soliloquy there Michael
you love I do say they have a shot okay
now last question for you Irv cuz we're
gonna hear this will be oh gosh we can
talk about it probably on our Saturday
pregame show we're gonna hear it all
week long teams that rested people did
you ever get rested before a playoff run
and did you like that or what's your
philosophy on on that we saw the rams
sit a lot of people we saw the Eagles
sit a lot of people we saw the Steelers
sitting a ton of people what while the
Patriots in the the Jaguars went like
they were playing for a playoff spot
what's your philosophy on on all this
earth usually I need to be in a locker
room to get an understanding or what
teams can and cannot handle that I I
personally like to try to get some
playing in I love the way Jimmy handled
it and because Jimmy always said we were
playing we were playing no one ever knew
when was not going to play Jimmy never
allowed a hint that when you were not
going the place so what you did was
prepare like you were playing all the
time and I always like this all right I
didn't want him to say well we're not
playing this week we're not going to
play this week and then I got Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
practices that I know I'm not going to
be able to place on a game anywhere so
now Monday I'm at practice Monday night
I'm out somewhere he may be out Tuesday
I'm at practice through the night
allowed evening they were having a
situation where some at practice night
about eating maybe have enough III you
see what you see pattern here I know I'm
not going to do it Sunday every night
I'm out eating I wanna have a free drink
but if you let me think that I'm going
to play
being those evenings are not happening
in the evening I'm over there on a
stepper going over my praise you see
what I mean I did that don't look back
that's the way that it worked best for
me and I I will go something like the
rails
they told me players early on you guys
you guys we aren't playing we're sitting
in these flares ah that's why I'm
telling you that's why last week Atlanta
they were all on board
cuz they needed to win that game so
they'll come into this game two weeks
straight focus with the land of top
players you know girl in all of God
taking a week off so it could work both
ways or maybe it helps them out because
they're banged up and we'll wait to see
but I like keeping my mines pressure
today herb see Saturday or the Friday
meeting before Happy New Year yeah
Friday Friday I happen to use everybody
man and they god bless every visiting
dream that years placed down in you to
come through in 2018 murder love you see
you soon love you too buddy that's
Michael Irvin so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience